I want to thank our demo presenters who
showed off some truly amazing projects
and the eye gaze technology is amazing
as well now lift computing can help
people with disabilities get around more
easily surely computer science can solve
the problems of privacy and security
that plague our connecting lifestyles at
least that's what I was hoping to learn
as we once more but research in focus
now we're all aware of security and
privacy concerns that surround our use
of emails and social media whether it's
phishing scams Trojan horses you name it
but now with the proliferation of mobile
devices that track our movements and
initiate interactions those concerns are
even more acute and if you like me
you're worried about keeping your
personal information safe I'm lucky I'm
joined by two experts on privacy and
security in this brave new world Peter
drew Shore who's the scientific director
of the Max Planck Institute for software
systems and stefan suru a senior
researcher at Microsoft Research welcome
gentlemen and you Peter we'll start with
you what concerns you most these days in
terms of privacy well one concern has to
do with these many popular applications
and services that keep track of people's
locations there are physical activities
their health status and increasingly
also their social encounters now in the
one hand these applications are
fantastic because they help people
organize their lives you know stay fit
and healthy and also get in touch with
some of the people in their vicinity but
on the other hand are these applications
and services really take the privacy
risks to an entirely new level because
they really blur the distinction between
online and offline worlds they're not
only recording you know your online
activity which is deliberate and
voluntary but they sort of seamlessly
track your physical whereabouts and that
is you know something that raises the
question of what happens to the data
that's being recorded and I think that's
something we'll really have to pay
attention to so they can get hold of the
information exploited I mean how exactly
do they do that well the problem starts
with the fact that these applications
really store and collect and store this
data and initially store it on your
mobile device so for instance if they
know you contract some malware which is
easy enough to do you go to the wrong
website you open an email attachment or
you fall for one of the phishing attacks
that malware can compromise your phone
and potentially get access and expose
that kind of data another important risk
is that you know many of these apps
actually upload that data to the app
providers cloud website and at that
point the user really has no control or
not even knowledge of what happens to
the data from that point on and and how
do we counter these threats are there
you know their tools or behaviors that
we should adopt prevent in its unwanted
slowing well in terms of tools they're
really there really isn't that much
available today in production right you
all know when you install an app you're
supposed to grant permission for that
app to installs or you know to access
certain information like your contacts
or you'll get access to certain sensors
like your location provider but quite
often write these requests seem
plausible to us and we're interested in
the functionality that this application
provides so we grant it and this is
really an all-or-nothing decision
because you know once the application is
access to the information we don't
really know and can't control what
happens you know how it's being used how
it's being disseminated now there is
quite a bit of research in the area
right there are people working on
techniques to try to track the flow of
information through such applications
there are people working on encryption I
think Stefan is that going to talk about
that a little bit we've also been
working on something towards developing
a communication platform then it enables
such apps to you know contact and
communicate with nearby devices but in a
way that keeps the user in control of
their privacy I'm I gather there's
another aspect and that's the privacy of
by standards and can you describe the
issue here yes so this is a related
aspect and it's got to do with the fact
that our smartphones and increasingly
variable devices have the sophisticated
audio visual audio visual capture
capabilities which has led actually to
commit highly new creative outlets you
know people are taking videos and
pictures all the time upload them on
facebook on YouTube that's a fantastic
thing but the thing that really hasn't
been addressed is that quite often in
social situations you know unrelated
bystanders just incidentally get
captured in
recording and in many situations they're
not actually okay with that right I mean
this is kind of a different issue isn't
it it short of going around getting
signed permission of all these people
and all these people might be on your
social media how can you invalid
invading their privacy well it's in that
you'd lead a challenge because on the
one hand you want to respect people's
privacy on the other hand you want to
preserve the spontaneity and ubiquity of
this kind of digital capture so we've
been working actually on a prototype
where the idea is to enable people to
state their preferences with respect to
capture privacy in depending on their
current context so they can say for
instance when I'm among friends you know
restrictions on image capture when I'm
at the workplace also no restriction but
when I'm in public you know I want to
have my face blurred and when I'm not at
the beach or a similar location like the
gym or a health care facility I don't
want to have my image captured at all
this would be recorded by my own smart
device my smartphone for instance and
then appetizer to nearby capture devices
over a short-range radio and capture
devices in their platform would then be
enabled to essentially receive this
press their preferences and check and a
captured image to see if some bystander
was captured and then you know edit the
media the video or the image to respect
that person's privacy and and how does a
public view these inadvertent privacy
invasions well that's an interesting
question there is some work on that from
social scientists and we've also done a
small-scale online survey on this and
essentially the outcomes are that on the
one hand people's preferences with
respect to this kind of capture are very
situational right it depends on the
context you know who's around me and I
among friends among strangers who's the
photographer right is it a friend is it
someone in some kind of an official
function like a wedding photographer or
is it a complete stranger and secondly
what we found this and others have found
as well is that there are considerable
individual differences among preferences
that people have in the same situation
so it seems to be a cultural and
personal thing and thanks very much
Stefan I'm I want to ask you the same
opening question I asked Peter what
concerns you most these days about
privacy in
purity so you know everything that Peter
said actually concerns me as well but
additionally i think that concerns me is
that the ease by which you know these
mobile devices that were carrying how
easily they're lost or stolen arguably i
think it's pretty clear that that mobile
you know smartphones and tablets are
much more easily lost or stolen than
desktops where are even laptops and um
can encryption solve this problem right
so so you know for a long time people
were worried about last devices
especially with laptops and both the
industry and research community
basically came up with these systems
that offer encryption of your data and
what they do is that the guarantee they
offer is called protecting data at rest
so whenever the data is stored on your
hard drive on your storage system the
data is encrypted and the keys that we
use to actually encrypt these data are
protected by some password or pin that
the user is asked to enter when these
devices actually start up and because
most of the time laptops are either shut
down or hibernating this is an adequate
sort of security model on the other hand
tablets and smartphones are rarely shut
down they are often in this sleep state
and only texts you know pressing the
power button actually the elysium
operation and have all these data are
lying unencrypted Lee in there ramps and
both enterprises and device owners are
very very concerned with a number of
attacks that can be mounted to still you
know data unencrypted data lying in
these devices memories I'm what kind of
attacks i mean you know other any
current or potential technological
solution yeah they definitely these
attacks have been known for a long time
you know they basically are referred to
in the literature as memory attacks and
one class of attacks are cold boot
attacks where we're actually it turns
out that when when a piece of memory
loses power it still preserve its
contents for a short period of time this
is referred to the data remnants
property that memory has so the attack
typically is that you know i can
basically steal your phone and maybe we
flush it with my own software and while
it's be flashing and going through that
reboot cycle i can the memory still
preserve some of it
that's an Ikea read them that way but
they're also but what's what they're
called bus monitoring the attacks were
actually look at the data that flows
between your your process or in the
memory and there are actually trivial
devices that actually inspect read this
memory traversing these buses in fact
there is a company that sells a buzz
marketing device that you can plug in
your iPad and transform your ipad into
this device that can trade secrets from
memory Wow and encryption technologies
I'm were they you know are they
available yes yes yes so so basically
what sort of the next barrier for us or
the next sort of goal for us is to make
sure that data stays or sensitive data
at the very least remains encrypted even
when it's in memory so the the model you
know the system that we're actually
going the words is one where every time
sensitive data leaves the boundary or
the perimeter of the processor is going
to be encrypted so the only place when
the data is actually unencrypted is in
the processor and mounting the tax on
the processor is much more difficult
much more costly and you know where we
build a system like that where you know
you can take your email or you and your
contact information and make sure that
whenever you process on that it has this
property that all data is encrypted when
it lies in memory um what do you suggest
people do in the meantime and how long
I've got to wait for right right this
encryption pro so encrypted memory
actually if you look at the industry
trends it's coming down the road the
hardware manufacturers are sort of you
know putting resources into coming up
with hardware solutions to make sure
that our memories encrypted at all times
nevertheless I harder only solution is
actually expensive and it's difficult to
adopt because building hardware is
expensive and deploying the practice
takes you know several iterations of the
market to sort of be near their devices
so that's why in the meantime we've been
working on software only solutions that
leverage today's hardware to actually
provide these guarantees nevertheless
the harder solution will be much more
performant much better so i expect
problem in about a decade that most of
the devices you're going to find these
stores are going to have at least some
form of ink
that memory in them and the Peter I'd
like you to ask answer the same sort of
question about how do people protect
themselves now in terms of social media
apps and from having information stolen
well I think the only general advice one
could give is to be judicious in
selecting application like a plus that
we install and services that we sign up
for right so in general one shouldn't
just evaluate these kinds of apps and
services by the functionality they
provide that's usually very appealing
but ask you know what data does is
collect is there a legitimate need for
that data to be collected and what
happens to that data later on now in
general it's difficult to answer these
questions particularly for a layperson
but one could for instance look you know
does the provider have a privacy
statement does that answer such
questions that I just asked right use
the provider a reputable company that
operates in a jurisdiction that can be
expected to to enforce these kinds of
rules and have laws that respect privacy
Stefan Peter thank you and for your
information is so if somewhat a little
bit dis questioning about privacy and
security in the world of mobile devices
and now let's go back to the vemma floor
where Scarlett has drummed up some
pretty information pretty good
information for us